hello everyone 2014 pass so quickly and
yet here we are starting to look ahead
to next year in 2015 We are continuing
to expand the world and characters we
know Europe and also create entirely new
experience I'm especially excited about
Wii U in
2015 because we will be delivering a
number of titles that emphasize the
system's unique
features 2015 is also a special year for
another reason it will be the 30th
anniversary of when we first released
Super Mario
Brothers right now we are developing
Mario maker with which anyone can easily
create their own Sid scrolling Mario
game and we are the of creation itself
is
fun I think this is going to be a
perfect fit for the 30th
anniversary today we are happy to share
some new Fage let's take a
[Music]
look
b
[Music]
tole b to
go
[Music]
take from me it wasn't this easy to make
Mario stages back in
1985 I'm very excited to see what
everyone create with Mario maker and who
knows one day Mario Maker may become a
popular series of it own I think you can
tell 2015 is going to be really fun for
wiu and Nintendo 3DS
owners I hope you are all having a great
time watching the game award until next
time
[Applause]
w